that's too long they like six
eight i'm supposed to catch listen
you're playing with the big boys now if
you want your madden rating to go up it
doesn't matter how
tall they are you're right you're right
i need tom brady out here though
[Music]
oh hello and welcome to underrated
presented by state farm not sure if you
know but state farm is known for two
things number one not being an actual
farm number two
they're surprisingly great rates you
know who else is going to surprise
people with their greatness this season
rookie wide receiver jerry judy i picked
him because i saw him in alabama
and his ratings are not high enough
there's only one thing we need to do
that's called matted all right jake
let's get judy's rating up
call my madden ratings adjuster calling
madden rate adjuster
clint old buddy old pal how you doing
you ever hear of jerry judy
oh yeah i've heard of jerry judy very
polished coming out of college
all right it's time jake call jerry judy
aka double
j get him on the phone calling double j
[Music]
there he is jerry judy a man of speed a
man of aggression
just look at him jerry this is clint
he's a madden ratings adjuster clint
this is the legendary jerry judy
all right man so i talked to clint over
at matt and i asked them to do something
that they have never done before they're
gonna give you the opportunity to
possibly raise your initial rookie
ratings do you like your ratings
a 74 that's a c
all right so there were two categories i
think you were actually very good at
where i think madden is sleeping on you
catching traffic and medium route
running but i want to start with
catching traffic first and
clint you're the guy to talk to how do i
improve these two
hmm all right so catching traffic what
we use that rating for
is determining the catch chance so if
you could come up with some drills to
test his concentration around
distractions while he's catching some
difficult passes uh that'd be a great
place to start
yeah i'm ready to improve that okay
clint medium route running what kind of
routes am i looking for to test this
uh you're looking at about the uh 20 to
40 yard range intermediate type routes
deep ends deep outs
uh we're going to be looking at his
footwork efficiency at the cut explosion
that's what i like to do right here rock
running this is me
i i mean jerry i gotta imagine never in
your life has anyone said you're a 74 in
football at any time
nah nah but hey like i said i just got a
show
clint are you going to take this serious
though i don't want them to do all these
routes and then you guys don't bump them
up
so we're the madden ratings adjusters we
always take this seriously
thanks clint i'll talk to you soon all
right take care
all right but since we couldn't put any
defenders out there to cover you we got
a little creative jerry
i call it the car dealership surprise
now jerry the nfl is different than
college when you cross the middle
there's going to be some amazing
defensive backs with
long wingspans so we've set up six sky
dancers and at the top of your route
they'll be fluttering in your face so
you gotta concentrate
and catch the ball i feel confident
though i've been doing this my whole
life
oh
that's one right though
[Music]
defense that's good defense right there
that's some good work
coming across the middle ah judy
dance on him oh
like it or not ladies and gentlemen
that's all we're going to be seeing in
denver for years to come
that was that was good i thought that
early on you were having some trouble
seeing them all but i feel like after a
while you got the hang of it no
that's not what it was you're wrong bad
throws
what yeah wait he running look he
running you see
listen but it's all good though you know
receiver got me the quarterback look
good
so uh unfortunately that's gonna hurt
your teammate rating though
i'm only kidding but you did kind of
throw him under the bus
jerry we're gonna have you run a few
medium range routes first i gotta show
you a little something
here is your new madden character doing
these routes and i want you to pay
special attention to how he moves
because i think we can convince the
adjuster
that you are way better than this
all right a little bit too bad nah i
ain't gonna lie that's not too bad
but i could do better you're loving this
right now look at your face though you
are loving it yeah it looks smooth
though i'm flying let's move
but i'ma show you smoothing tear up the
earth jerry judy
that was a dime right there a good throw
ah been down with me been down with me
all right talk to me man
it's different running routes on air
and running rocks against a defender
against the defender
you're doing more moves hesitating oh
then stop by that so it's kind of
different
are you tired right now yeah
i'm back we're in a corner post
yeah i want to see the man in action i
want to see the release
y'all see the footwork though he got
back up so you see his footwork the
footwork was get him
that's what i want to see
what happened jerry the wing got a hold
of it that was a bad one
hair got my face a little bit it touched
my hand though no excuses
you know what we're gonna learn from
this we're gonna get right back at it
yes sir
let's get back to it
came out ahead i'll say this man if you
can fake the hat off your head you're
going to fake defenders out of their
shoes that was perfect
appreciate it now i'm going to take all
this i'm going to send it to my homie
madden do you think that we put good
film on tape today
i think so i think i ran some good
routes i think we did pretty good today
you got any choice words you'd like for
me to include with your submission tape
i better be at 80 by the end of the day
well hold on to that because when i call
you next time i'm gonna have the
adjuster on the line and you can tell
her right to his face
hey adam man i'm looking forward to for
you let me know what i did today
um and to see if it could improve my
rating
i got you man we're gonna talk soon
[Music]
clint i'm telling you the kid is young
but he is going to be a stud
the video showed it what were your
reactions let me know the truth
and we saw some really good things we
saw some things that could use some
improvements
uh you know good video good research
let's get jerry judy on the call
jerry judy in the car hey jerry
what's up man clint you said there's
adjustments let me hear what these
adjustments are
so we are going to actually bump him up
one point in medium rock running
he is the number one rated rookie in
medium route rep
i did all that weird just get one
percent yeah it's tough man for a rookie
we gotta leave some room
to grow for you young kids for
consolation
i can tell you that based on some of the
athleticism you showed running through
those
flying waving banners you are going to
go up one point
in short route running as well hey
okay so we went up a point medium and a
point in short it'll be a little bit
better we're making progress
it's all good clint i'm putting it all
on you let's get down to it
is jerry judy underrated i'm gonna say
in this case
no even though there is going to be an
adjustment
no we have jerry rated pretty close to
accurate
um well yeah i agree
double the was a little bit because the
quarterback wasn't great
i'm bringing quarterback on that one
jerry you're the man clint i appreciate
it i love both of you
and jerry's going to be in 99 by next
season i can feel it
deal with it this has been underrated i
am adam lufko and as always we are
sponsored by these surprisingly great
rates
of state farm check them out
you